hi there's another handout
today um do people have it far it's
called a data
sheet it's it's one I'm I planed to hand
out actually last time but it's it tells
uh what the whole course is is about and
uh the main thing I think some of you
will be interested in knowing is the
purpose of the course and the and the
method of grading it um and so the uh uh
just wanted to reiterate something I
said quickly before that the main thing
in this course will be that we'd like
you all each to write a term paper on a
subject of your own choice and uh this
has the uh there's an extra gimmick here
that I don't mind in fact it's fine if
you if you also had to write this paper
anyway the main thing is that that that
now you get an extra incentive to write
it very beautifully and uh somebody
talked to me on Wednesday that he's uh
he's writing a book in physics and uh
and it's okay to turn in a chapter the
book for his turn paper that's all right
yes uh but you don't all have to turn in
that much uh I was thinking that was
something about 10 to 20 pages and the
main thing that you should know now is
that on Wednesday November 18th I'd like
we'd like a rough
draft um uh something that can be turned
in for for the sake of criticism and uh
and
review uh before it's too late to change
anything and uh the the main thing is uh
that you should have um a good something
that you're interested in writing and
you have a good idea as to what as to as
to a kind of form that it's supposed to
fulfill it doesn't have to be any
specific form when I say term paper it
could be any really all kinds of
different things uh are are possible um
I was uh I was thinking of having a a
contest for the for the best Pascal
program that was also a Sonet uh uh now
that would probably not be the best for
this course but I'm that's a form you
know that anybody read the um uh Golden
Gate the uh novel with all the table of
contents and everything is in 14 line
stanzas and so on well you should be
able to do that with a pascal program
too right uh but um uh there are many
different kinds of forms that you have
as and um and one of them is a chapter
in a book one of them is a journal paper
one of them is a is a uh exposition of
um something that you think ought ought
to be explained well uh
some you should have your audience in
mind who who you're writing it for it
could be uh it doesn't have to be um me
at all it could be any any particular
kind of audience that you that you uh
have firmly in mind is somebody worth
worthwhile that that you want to write
something for but that's the the main
thing is uh uh that that you that you
have some specific genre in mind but I
don't have one in mind and and just do a
good job on whatever on whatever that is
there's a uh there's another possibility
I should mention is H Computer programs
uh uh a well-written computer program
with with
documentation um is uh is a kind of
literature that's uh that of course
that's probably too hard to do that uh I
mean it's it's not as it uh but but any
any kind of uh
technical uh technical writing it would
is is okay in this turn paper as long as
it's um as long as it's U not not not
trivial I guess uh I used to assign my
my kids
uh I said they should write uh 50 words
originally it was a week in order or i'
turn off the TV set and uh and they had
to turn in their essays and then it got
to be 100 Words and so on my my and uh
when my son discovered uh once he he
wrote about the 49ers game and he said
in the first quarter the 49ers scored
seven points and and the other team
scored three points in the second
quarter the 49 and you got up to and he
got up to 50 words very easily that way
um so then I had to make a rule no no
writing about sports events unless you
use varied vocabulary or something
anyway um you get the idea that uh the
idea in the ter paper is something that
you're interested in doing a good job
and not just and not for me to really
spell out the a for formal requirements
which you which you look over like a
lawyer and and try to uh to see to to
optimize the minimum amount of time to
do you
okay lawyers actually try to maximize
the amount of
time okay the minimize the amount of uh
something or other they maximizing is
always the opposite of minimizing or
minimizing the the negative okay um now
uh as I said I want to go through the
other uh papers that were turned in and
uh because they they raised interesting
issues I think uh in fact almost
everything that I'll be mentioning here
was was something that at least two
people did uh so it's uh it's worth it's
worth of uh worth noting and um but I do
want to get through be sure to get
through it all I'm not going to I'm not
going to drag on this whole course
talking about uh L of c and P which can
get pretty tiresome so this will be the
this will be today we'll we'll have done
with non-increasing vectors okay now all
right uh let's see this one see if I can
figure out what I did here
um um I first of all I have there's a
colon here we show the contrapositive
colon we assume that and such and and so
on uh I um now this is this is a a point
that I don't have much support for
outside of my but I but I've uh always
wondered should you cap should you
capitalize the letter after a colon or
not and and um and I I'm probably you'll
get different people telling you
different things um and I've um evolved
something that's worked for me rather
well in the past few years and so and I
I I suggest it to you but if you don't
like it uh you can lump it uh the the uh
U and that is I I
capitalize the the thing after a colon
if it's a sentence if it's a complete
sentence subject and predicate but if
it's a fragment of a sentence that
doesn't have that doesn't then I leave
it then I leave it lower case um so this
case I would have capitalized the the
the wi here because it's going to turn
out to be a sentence but that's just an
extra clue to the reader that you know
sort of that this colon was was actually
a pointer to the to another sentence
rather than a pointer to the completion
of the of the present sentence um
question a question on that yeah do you
throw in an extra space before the
capital letter and you do that uh uh
well actually Tech has already thrown in
an extra space after the colon uh it it
treats a colon and and a period and a
and but uh uh that would help too if
you're if you're on a typewriter or
something like that yeah then uh double
space at the end of a sentence is is a
kind of a neat thing sometimes sure um
that's a but uh and then would be even
harder to put a lowercase letter then
after after an extra space no that
that's a that's a a thought that no how
about how about if the sentence is like
a less than b where A and B in or
variables in lower case let know how
about if the sentence is a less than a
is the sentence is a is less than B that
follows Theon that's that starts that's
a sentence starting with a symbol you
don't I would rewrite it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um if it's displayed it's okay U now
let's see I have a point here one one
pass no look ahead um that's in the pre
it suffices to prove that L of CP
contained in a of n
c uh not equal empty and c and and imply
now uh imply grunt okay so um it's not
clear when when I
was when I was reading this that that
this word imply would change the whole
the whole ball game uh you know we it's
suffices to prove that and then we do
listing things and all of a sudden I was
going to you know I thinking I'm
supposed to prove that that L of CNP is
is contained in this and but I'm not
really proving that I'm proving that the
you know that all of this impli that
which which is uh impossible I think to
read this sentence without look ahead
and so some some way of giving a clue to
what was happening um you know uh that
the the three conditions l c and P so on
imply then uh if if you if you say uh if
you say that it probably helps a little
bit any okay um now let's see there's
another thing that's very common I think
it's probably because uh let's see I put
some in here unfortunately this format
is wider than our TV
screen
um what do I have an end
oh sorry I can't
remember why I said
c oh yeah here it is um we have bi less
than bi + 1 for some B and P and I and
one less than or equal I less than n now
I would have put an extra sum in here
and sum one less than or equal I uh it
it's uh some people don't like to to say
sum and then give a relation where the
where the the object of the sum is is I
uh but um depending on our audience it
would be okay I think to make that much
of but here it looks like this this this
is confusing without saying whether you
want all I or or some I in this range uh
I I think that uh that's hard to
understand what you mean so so you have
b i for some B and some I in and I if
you wanted to be completely clear about
you would say n some I in the range 1
less than or equal I less than
n uh and then let's see then K greater
or equals z comma because C is contained
in a subn comma and hence such and such
um I just thought the word and here was
a little bit uh wordy um
uh it just for me the flow would I would
have costed I would have said thenk then
something because something hence
something um the end hence didn't but I
can't explain why I
just um thought that would be a small
Improvement um okay here's here's an
interesting thing about commas
um uh the lack of them observe first
that if L of c and P is the subset of a
and then so is C because
okay um now there's this is a
complicated uh uh German I guess they
would call it Shak shakat it's not quite
saying but uh it's a Bo it's a it's got
a lot of of things because if first that
if something so then so is because um I
I would uh at least put a comma after C
here in order to in order to take a
breath and and uh we
got uh certainly putting in too many
commas would would would spoil it
because you wouldn't be a you'd have to
rewrite the sentence you you would it
would get so it would it would sound as
infut as it is but if you leave out the
comments you can you can at least read
this at high speed and and it's and it's
uh it's simple enough to to internalize
but then you need a comma at least there
if then and because all that that was
that was I think going a little too much
there
um uh here it says to that end assume by
contradiction that remember we had this
trouble the other the other day um uh
there's there are nicer ways to to say
uh we're going to uh prove something by
contradiction and we'll we saw some
examples already and there'll be some
more coming up okay otherwise this was
actually rather good oh yeah one more
comment on this uh um the end of the
proof uh I think Paul helish was the guy
who invented this idea of having a
symbol at the end of a at the end of a
proof and it's it's pretty nice in a
textbook actually when you know that uh
something about the structure there you
don't have to say QED or um or saying
this completes the proof and so on so
you can just put this little this little
symbol there um and um I would have just
put a little space between the period
and the symbol but and there sometimes
people use a solid bar but uh anything
like that is a is fairly a fairly good
idea uh but there but why why does it
follow the period immediately that's
that it doesn't seem quite right to me I
don't
know uh minor points obviously mixed up
with some other that are more
important
um okay let's see
uh I like this uh now to prove a to
prove this uh let us assume the opposite
and see what
happens um I think that's kind of
nice
um why do I have where
there I don't I I have a note here that
I can understand forget that um okay now
let's
see um
and uh sometimes there's a question
should we put the word that in there now
now to prove that P is let us assume the
opposite um here I don't feel the need
for it
um and I it's a matter of rhythms things
that I don't fully understand but but uh
here was a was a situation where it
sounded very nice uh because every
uh maybe it's cuz prove is a one
syllable word and assume is a two-
syllable word I don't think that's it um
but now to prove that it wouldn't
wouldn't be bad to put the word that in
there but it sounds okay to me now some
sometimes I feel strongly that I got to
put the word that in and you'll you I I
hope I don't get too hung up on it in
this course I'll try not to bore you
with too much anyway main thing here
though was a was a kind of a nice um uh
uh uh break in the in the action saying
see what happens um uh it's sort of uh
let's let's do an experiment that's kind
that's that's a reasonable thing to do I
think uh uh to to show the method of by
which a proof is is is sort of unrolls
by itself instead of uh instead of
afterwards now now this you can do if if
the proof uh is is uh simple like this
one is if it's if you had to if you had
to let all proofs unroll by themselves
then you couldn't prove very complicated
theorem
sometimes
um that let us take as given that such
and such and P and and C equals z we
will show that this implies that c is
contained
in um there sometimes there's too many
thats in a row and it's too bad but uh
we will show that this implies that I
would try to get around it by maybe
saying both or something I would say
that I we will show that this implies
both see something I don't know uh
something I I I I do feel a need for a
beat in here after the word implies and
uh perhaps uh but there but there is a
you can also put in that so often um
gets it gets
tiresome um now here's a present tense I
thought said I was going to talk a
little about tenses here we assume now
that P is is such and such and will show
that this leads to contradiction so we
got to so so now we got this and then
later uh this will lead this this uh
this was going to we're going to show
something um uh and
um
um somehow it's read awkward to me
because the because we're mixing tenses
we're assuming you know the the the we
is being
is is omitted in the second part of the
sentence it sort of carries over the
same subject but here's the subject
using once with the present tense and
once with a future tense um uh so it
might
be uh better to say something like we
assume now hoping to show that this
leads to contradiction or something like
that in hopes of showing that this lead
I don't
know um
hopefully um oh there's another
handout and uh and I have a handout
about hope hopefully that's uh that's
come here and and uh I plan to discuss
this next week um now the uh the thing I
want to discuss about this handout
there's some content to it it talks
about the word hopefully but the main
thing I want to talk about is the style
of writing in the in the handout itself
this the form is much more important to
me and the way the the the beautiful way
this is this is uh uh these these points
are covered these would apply to
mathematical writing as well as writing
about English and uh and so so the uh
this little this is a sort of a model
little essay of U about about how to
write explain a technical Point um and
the technical points that are made are
also of relevant but mostly uh I like
just the form of the of the writing
we'll talk about it next week sometime
um okay now
um uh here was another case where
elements are are being
you know could would be better
components again it's um because we have
elements and components both we talked
about that on
Friday um and
um
uh and there was one thing that U the
the person here decided not to introduce
the um the variable K in the proof but
to keep copying out CI minus CJ + one
over and over each time you see in all
these proofs um while the original had a
K in there
um uh and and uh I didn't think there's
a win in this in this case the formulas
just get long and uh it's it's easier to
do a lot of the manipulations at a
higher level with K so I would have said
uh where where V is defined as V = C +
KU uh K = cius CJ + 1 uh and I think
then the rest of it a lot of this K's
would have would have would have gone
here shortened everything you know and
and uh and and we can recall the
definition of k then when we finally get
to the punchline but carrying it all the
way through the all the way through is
sort of it sort of uh violates the
principle of name and Conquer that helps
to helps to make mathematics
intelligible um LMA one here I would
have capitalized as I say it's the
proper
name okay next um
oh here's something about uh about tech
again there's there's a
um a I would have put a tie in my tech
file after the word of and before as
subn you see how as suben is a little uh
I don't know if it's called a widow or
an orphan or or whatever it's all alone
there at the very much anticlimax by
itself at the end of the at the end of
the paragraph now um there are places
that uh that people would not break a
line if they were if they were doing it
on a
typewriter and this is one of them uh
and and I I made a study of uh of um
what happened when computers took over
the type setting job in in in journals
and and ACM Journal used to be done by
hand where everybody would make a manual
decision where to break a line You' push
a button on his monotype machine and it
would and uh and it would it would eject
the line it would be set in lead and go
to the next line and um and I counted
the th pages of the Journal of the ACM
in those days as to how many times I
found breaks like this with this
anticlimax uh afterwards and then I I
made the same count uh I think there
were something like four in a th pages
okay and I made the same count after
computerized type setting came in '70s
and uh and it was something like 54 uh
so there was know it might have been
that people started writing sentences
that had more occurrences of these
things I haven't you know I haven't
really got a controlled sample here uh
but it seems to me that there that
something uh was done when people were
using a human judgment on breaking lines
that was lost went which exctly so I I I
tie it together now now in in Tech
there's a symbol that if in in in in PL
Tech there's a there's a convention that
if you if you that if you type a instead
of a space then it's an unbreakable
space it's a space that will that will
be everything every everything like
every other space except that the line
won't end there and um and anyway I
discovered that this was that this was
happening in in uh in computer type
setting that many time this happens much
more in mathematics than other kinds of
writing um and it was these these funny
breaks were occurring more often and so
um and so I said I wonder printers if
printers ever had a name for this uh
kind of a kind of a space that you don't
that you don't break after is there a
way to specify to the U to the best
commercial type setting systems that
have a space and don't do it and I met a
guy from York Graphics who was one of
was one of the better better composition
houses and he said yeah we call this an
auxiliary space and and uh and we some
sometimes use it then I then I found
actually some some uh literature I had
to go back into the 19th century and and
and found a French book on on typ
setting which actually talked about this
that you wouldn't uh if you were
mentioning only the the fourth however
you say fourth in French uh you wouldn't
uh break a line between those two uh uh
Lor and so on you would and um and he
gave several other other examples where
it would would would would be U um bad
form to to break a um to break a line so
anyway um auxiliary space didn't turn me
on so I called it a tie and and um when
I when I'm now
proofreading um a paper that I that I've
typed said or or Phyllis uh and I see a
place where where uh I I would would
rather not break there I just put this
symbol there and that means put a Tilla
in your manuscript and then and then the
tech won't do that I think other systems
are going to be getting this and it
turned out to be very simple to to to to
do this almost without thinking as
you're typing so I would have put a tie
for example as I'm typing this I would
put a tie there uh usually if if I have
a an and followed by one other thing um
a subset of and to the N I probably
would have typed typed an of there and
Phyllis does this
automatically um ofp here I would have
put a tie and and a few places in the
manuscript I get to use that usually at
the end of a sentence where there's
where there's a one symbol thing coming
in there uh sometimes um uh like if I
had to put a tie here I wouldn't have
put it before the Asin I would have put
it after the Asin I'd rather have the
break after since but but it I don't
feel too strongly about that one but
anyway there are cases where ties um um
definitely help this this actually
question yeah when you look through the
Thousand Pages for awkward breaks was it
subjective or objective I mean did you
have a a spelled out criteria for what
constit a it was where I where I yeah it
was it was subjective it was a I call it
psychologically a bad break where where
somehow it would it would be a let down
to get to the other the line and see
that see that thing by itself this was
first called to my attention by readers
of the original tech manual in the late
7s when um when I would being refering I
would refer to chapter and then it would
say one period and they said Don you got
the best type setting system but why
does it do that and um and and and I
became sensitive to it and that's I made
my experiment why why isn't in Tech
automatically to take care of problems
like that well um it does there is no
automatic rule I don't think I mean it's
a matter of judgment okay it's if if
it's a very short if it's a very short
word you can you you could probably
predict that nobody would want to break
there that's true and but that really
doesn't happen that often with a short
word because Tech has a pays a penalty
for for the number of lines in a
paragraph So it much prefers to to set a
two-line paragraph than a three-line
paragraph So the so it sort of said it
sort of needed a three-line paragraph
but then it took the best uh the best
three line par gra it could find it
didn't it didn't it didn't have this on
the uh on the end so so uh you could you
could do that by setting your your power
the space at the end of a paragraph and
say that you don't want that to stretch
so easily it it stretches with no no
penalty at all at the moment but but
that's uh uh yeah uh I
I um I I find though that it occurs in
the middle of a sentence as well as in
the as as well as at the end of
sentences and and but it's in the noise
level it's not something that I have to
even be conscious of after after the
first at the first few times of putting
it in so so um uh um anyway it's it's
something that that can be done for spit
and
polish um now this you can't see it too
well on TV but uh but bold face is used
here uh these vectors are bold the C and
P are bolder than the other ones we have
a nice black uh this laser printer was
was had a real good in ribbon here so
that b is bold compared to the other one
there and so so person's using that that
aspect of typography it seems to help a
little bit uh on this one but it's not
terribly necessary if you work with if
you work with a lot of vector I don't
know it did but it did help I think and
uh I kind of like this um this saying
here the the proof that P containing is
by contradiction remember we had this
problem of how to State this um and and
uh this is this sets everything up and
uh it's a present tense it says it is by
contradiction instead of it will be by
contradiction that's
fine
um I for which Pi less than PJ pi and PJ
weren't H strictly speaking defined
there but I but I only had one real
serious complaint about this and that is
I said oops when I got to this line here
um you see here's two
form formulas right right in a row got
to put some something in there in
between to uh to to separate those those
formulas um I don't know what would say
component DJ must be goodal
n
um but it's not too nice to have those
two in a row other than that this was
fairly good still I sp
there
um okay here's
uh uh what did I mark this parallel okay
we are given that such by taking m
equals 0 and two we see that such and
such by transitivity of C we have that
um uh okay two sentences in a row with
the same thing but there's a sort of a
parallelism there why the comma the
second one and not the first I don't I
don't know
um um but I did but this was was was
reasonable I would have uh I'm not sure
whether these are new paragraphs or not
this um uh it looks like each one is a
new paragraph but there's no way for me
to to really tell but here I would
definitely start a new paragraph with
this transition now we shall prove that
P contained an N um and this leads me to
comment about the word shall
um uh the uh the style of the art of
computer programming that my copy editor
taught me was to say sh when I'm making
a definition we shall say that we shall
call u p and and it somehow didn't sound
formal when I read it in the gy proofs
even though shall is a rather formal
word we don't talk that way now um
otherwise I typically would say
will um not meaning we will do it but
but just uh uh it wasn't uh somehow
shell sounded right in definitions the
way that copyeditor Dred it into my mind
now in the in the book that I'm writing
now with Orin he doesn't like shell it
sounds very formal to him and he comes
from a generation closer to the to
audience that we're trying to reach here
so uh uh so it must be that shell is is
a lot more um
uh it goes into it goes into my
Consciousness I mean it you know it goes
into my head without being conscious
that it's formal um while with younger
readers it it's different so probably uh
will would would would sound better to a
to a um uh to a je to a to a young uh
what do you call it a
um a student of the of the
80s
um okay now people some people use
arrows over over their vectors um vector
t with instead of you know just like a
typographic convention putting it in
bold face and that uh uh I suppose that
can be helpful if you're used to it I uh
physicists seem to like it and and uh
and uh yeah it's all
right
um it doesn't it doesn't go I mean some
people put put a uh a a bold face Tilda
underneath every Vector there's all
kinds of different symbols and depending
on what you're used to uh go for it and
figure out what your audience is used to
what you like uh here's on this one um
this is a a mark written in the in the
margin by whoever did this paper
um uh I say I know CJ and p i j is
confusing here here it says Suppose
there is a vector P sub I and P which is
not in a sub
n um of course this
is that of course
um why call it pie of I why not call it
P
yeah I know it's confusing
all
um and again here was the idea says
future tense we will use the proof and
to show or we it's it's okay we use a
proof wouldn't sound too good here uh by
contrast uh we can use a proof I suppose
how does uh we prove this by
contradiction we prove this by
contradiction yeah that's rather good
yeah in fact use a proof is a little bit
uh uh wordy isn't it yeah
thanks okay um here's somebody who loves
colons Lima proof we prove each result
separately Colon c contain colon Define
this as follows
col this is this is this is really a
wind for colon okay so um
um oh no here here they get into comma
mode okay right therefore comma
something something comma and since
comma by hypothesis comma such comma we
have all right um so uh yeah you can do
without few of these
commas
uh why you have this and since in
there
um uh I and I would probably throw the
this this after you know since and since
such and such by hypothesis it probably
because otherwise there's too much it's
just broken up too much and a person can
re can uh can wait to find out that it's
by hypothesis until after after it's
been stated um okay so you can get rid
of the colons um uh uh by just
uh
uh for example this one isn't needed to
isn't really needed
um okay uh this one I would definitely
take out uh we we have such and such
that that's part of the sentence it it
it it just completes the sentence and it
doesn't have to have a colon in there
but this Define it as follows the colon
is good there I'm not against all colons
just some and uh because that's the end
of a sentence and and now we we have a
call we're pointing to the we're
pointing to the thing that that we're
going to do as in the following
way now
um uh here's something that several
people that several people did and I I
wonder now look at this it says QJ
greater than Qi and and in n greater
than or equal J greater than IAL 1 but
the vector Q has been listed explicitly
1 2 up to n now does something strike
you about this um here we're seeing the
we're seeing everything displayed left
to right one two up to n but somehow
when we give this condition we're
displaying the the subscripts in the
opposite order it's it's violates you
you know it would be much nicer I think
to say Qi less than qg
today uh I mean unless you're into real
dominance you know you like to always
say greater than you don't like the word
less than um and then you could you
could rewrite this one uh you know
coming back that way in this in the
order in which it's already been
presented because then somebody can see
that you're having a less than relation
in in there which you didn't want um the
definition was given in terms of of of
greater than or equals uh otherwise it
doesn't look like a much of a violation
until you got here and saw that they and
saw saw which way the days are going to
so you so so you get to choose the way
to present an inequality uh and uh try
to do it in a way that's re that's is
Meaningful isn't the one less than and
less than equal to n also somewhat
redundant I mean yeah that's that's true
because uh it's not really it's not yeah
s we're not writing a computer program
here we're we're we're communicating
with an intelligent uh being who would
probably understand for some I less than
J uh because otherwise they're
undefined yeah
good point um now uh we several other
people also did this we should should
have given any increasing Vector like Q
it is always possible to add enough
copies on now increasing is probably not
a a good term there uh because it's
really only increasing partially it's
not it's it's not totally nonincreasing
but it's it's not totally increasing
either necessarily nonre non non
increasing yeah I could call it a
partial I could get by with it by saying
it's a partially increasing Vector like
Q it's always possible to add enough
copies or something like that okay and
there's a quite a few quotes in here
um
uh um I I guess I if you want to it's
okay to have a few quotes but maybe I
would say any partially increasing
without without putting them in quotes
like like you and then I could say maybe
enough in quotes uh it to be a little
cute and then uh and then say a
partially increasing resultant Vector
but to have three to have three cute
things in quotes in in one sentence is a
little too
cute
okay
um okay uh I like the um uh this the the
way this ended just for synchronization
it it it it keeps the audience the
reader in uh this this proof seems to do
a rather good job of keeping the keeping
the track of where we are and so on and
and says this completes the second part
of our proof was a um was a uh a
reasonable uh way to uh uh to lock
everything
up um if I were by the way in inside
Tech I would have put a tie here and and
there um uh and and here and stuff you
know
um uh
well one other comma I would I would
leave out this comma therefore therefore
I wouldn't say therefore El might be I
would just say therefore how do you feel
about those double closing parentheses
definition CL parentheses that's not too
good yeah that's interesting um uh
that's
um
um it's it's uh it was here it was here
that that that he introduced it so so so
so we we got ready for it here uh now um
yeah remember definition one that's an
interesting point here it says remember
definition one that's a it's a it's a
injunction to the reader remember
definition one it's kind of a uh it's a
little bit of break and style if you go
from wi to to U uh but um it seemed to
it seemed to read fine and then since we
have that then we already we remember
the word remember so this this sounded
okay now um the uh but it is um uh may
be awkward to have parenthesis inside of
parenthesis to some to some audiences it
depends
on on the
what I would Pro I would uh well since
see see all did it did have a
parenthesis in the definition so I can't
just leave off the if if if if I were
able to make the definition without
parenthesis that would be okay uh but
um
um uh
the only the only other solution I think
is to is to take out the parenthesis
around this remember definition one and
make it a make it a dash or something
like that question or or another
sentence Yeah by is it standard form to
if you have nested parentheses like that
to make the outside one brackets uh oh
that's a thank I'm glad you asked that
um there was a time when it was standard
form to to go from parenthesis to
brackets to braces and then uh I'm not
sure what they did next um and then and
then um uh and then mathematicians
started using braces and brackets
for
semantical purposes so that braces and
brackets were were different from
parentheses um like you know you use
braces around a set and you use brackets
for the greatest integer or whatever it
or whatever it is or for a subscript or
something like that then Fortran came
along and everybody realized that
actually if you just have for is um you
can still figure it out which matches
with which in principle anyway okay now
uh however typ Setters when they have
parenthesis instead inside a parenthesis
we we'll actually make a large
parenthesis we'll make this parenthesis
a little bit
bigger uh um and and in especially in a
math in a math formula like if you're
saying Min of parenthesis f ofx g ofx or
something like that these are these are
slightly larger parenthe is that they'll
typ set for that but uh um but uh I
would
never uh go to Men of bracket f ofx g
ofx now unless I was writing a uh uh
something for third graders who um whose
teacher had learned this old convention
and still thinks it's correct or
something but but it's really gone this
whole this whole idea of of of changing
parenthesis to to braces and brackets
and so on is is very Obsolete and
dangerous because uh semantics have now
been I mean uh
world is short of delimiters and people
are packing interesting meanings into
delimiters uh these days so so uh
different sizes of parenthesis are
better than different different U
different kinds of parenthesis I think
very strongly about
that another question yeah um with the
remember definition two further up yeah
uh isn't that a complete sentence one
should that be punctuated capitalized
and
everything um no because it's it's
thrown in as a clause so I don't know
yeah uh if you could um if you if if if
so you would put the period here and
then you have here but I I don't know
it's it's th it's it's short enough that
I that I that I think putting
in I don't know maybe I I guess I don't
like it as much as I did when I first
saw it but U it doesn't it it didn't it
didn't hurt me too much to see that in
there as I as I write as I write I um in
my handwritten manuscript um by the way
I have to confess that I don't uh enter
my original draft uh my my very first
creation is very rarely done done at a
computer can can a professor of computer
science confess not to using computers
for everything um but then I I type it
after I from my pencil draft and I and I
I change it as I go and one of the
common changes I make is to remove
parentheses things that sounded
parenthetical to me when I first first
wrote them uh aren't very parenthetical
or they don't sound right in parenthesis
when I read them at speed and um and so
uh putting too many things in
parenthesis uh can can be a stylistic
thing that that'll get very tiresome in
in in in a few pages um but having it
once in a while is is okay I'm running
out of time yeah question on previous um
paper this one before this one yeah the
yellow one um yellow yeah they should be
the other one um there is a for some
I where are we let's see maybe it's not
this one no you want to
go yeah right for some I less than
J where are we um up a little up a
little right there here right given any
increasing Vector like Cur it is ALS oh
for some I less than J yeah right um
okay well it's actually for some I and
for some J such that they satisfi this
condition but how's you want I mean is
this okay yeah I can I could say for
some I less than J I think that's okay
but if I was if I you know it's really
for some I and some J such that I less
than J or for some I and J such that I
and j i but I I'm I'm used enough to
this maybe other people think it's going
too fast now what about other type of
more cumbersome
formulas um I I I'll uh
uh I I I personally don't mind stringing
together
um uh two equal signs in a row for
example things like that if it happen
something like for for I um IAL say the
ceiling function of r cosine of J you
whatever big then I would have to
reformulate it yeah but but the main
point is I wanted to get this condition
out in a meaningful way but but in a
hurry I I I uh because inj had because
inj were the were the were the undefined
things in the preceding phrase I mean Qi
less than QJ I andj aren't defined yet
and so so I want to I want to get to I
want to say as quick as possible what I
andj are in some way that will that will
that that won't uh confuse the the flow
of the of the discussion and I think
that does it for some ILS andj for for a
person who who uh is uh sophisticated
enough to to be interested in L c&p in
the first place
uh all right now I put the word that in
here let us assume that so and so on
sorry
um now here you see they did it good
assume that P is not a subset of as subn
it worked um in other words there is an
n n is in the wrong font here
um uh would be uh better to put it in
italics uh like the letter N the word
tupal is kind of interesting it's a new
word in English been invented in the
last 10 or 20 years I think
um uh and now here is really there exist
indices i1 and I2 now this person was
just trying to put me on here such that
x sub I sub one is less than x sub I sub
2 um uh okay yes uh question about n if
I say the N component or so yes is this
like is fine is is n italics DT Roman or
uh yes that actually uh I would I I I
typically keep it in Roman I had it here
in um in italic and uh here's an
interesting example where are
we uh yeah boy I got a lot to go here
but I'm going to going to hit really
highlights let's see where is the
one
ah here here we go I component okay here
was done with italic see I would prefer
that in Roman look look at here the I
plus first component so you know how
that works out now now you can you can
do that if you raise the St otherwise
you'd have to if the St was down the
line you have to put that in
parenthesis
um I have a question about when you
decide to uh display things put them out
separately display kind of equation when
you just stick them in line right um
there's it's displayed usually when it's
something that needs to be seen as a uh
it's it's it's important to to be
visualized uh in its totality I guess we
we'll talk more about that later um uh P
people are also display things when
they're trying to make page format come
out nicely and uh sometimes the the uh
the editors of my book they when they
were in the old days would uh uh when
they were doing it by hand they would
they would display some formula that
that just hadn't you know it sort of
said and therefore X is a is a subset of
something and and X was all by itself it
was just ridiculous but they needed to
to fill out the you know I so I wrote a
couple more sentences so that they so so
that the page would would be all right
um here's an example of two things in a
row that's wor by adding p k times to C
notice that that doesn't work
right okay here's uh let's divide the
proof into two parts first proving C and
then then proving P I like that thought
that was
good
um uh let's see um uh here it says can
the the definition of LC P can be
paraphrased as the subset of n to the N
obtained by adding zero or more
indistinct elements of P to all elements
of C quote period okay now here I would
have put the the period inside the quote
I we talked about that um
indistinct elements isn't the right word
um
possibly the same elements but that that
that detracts from the paraphrase
because the next sentence says the
operative word here is zero and so
indistinct is just a is is is is being
being being crazy uh being a strange
word it sounds like the operative word
so forget that zero or more elements you
know that's a red herring of the
indistinct part to all elements the
operative word here is zero that's good
you know it's a nice way to to phrase
the I would really like to to read a
book written by this person in general
um and zero here uh the the quote before
the period that's fine because that's
the operative word zero itself is being
quoted here but somehow when we quoting
a sentence I would put the period inside
here it says the Lemma is half proved I
love that um uh just a u it's uh you
know uh um and in fact it was the
trivial part of the of the Lemma but uh
okay but anyway I thought this was a re
it is left to show that P containing as
subn assume that P is not contain as
subn that is assume there exists a oh I
probably would have put it that assume
that there exists a vector such an NP
that is non-increasing we will see that
this leads to a contradiction it's a
very good transition paragraph I said I
probably enjoy this
UT um that's future tense is okay if
this if it's used consistently
um uh spelling is occasionally um I
should say something about spelling
argument here and uh people is not being
able to spell is not a symptom of being
um unintelligent it's just uh it's just
one of the varieties of intelligence
that some people have uh and that they
don't they don't see spelling errors and
other people do and the people who do
are offended by it so so the people who
who don't should learn how to cope with
this by using spelling Checkers and
things like that
otherwise it'll it'll
it'll okay well let's see
um it can be shown by contradiction that
P is also contained in N that's a p
that's a good example of passive voice
which be improved by making it active a
proof by contradiction shows that P is
also contained and things like that okay
um since we know that such is contained
in as suben we don't know it necessar I
don't know why we know that piece L it
was never assumed we don't know things
like that
so how are we doing on time here I'm
running out of
time but I promise not to do this
anymore
um after today well let's see what are
the
great here's somebody who wrote in all
caps uh this it sounded like to me like
it was shouting the whole thing
um but but we got into subjective mood
here suppose that there were some vector
and so on a subjunctive mood uh that's
um uh it
doesn't I I think uh you don't have to
be so subjunctive there and you would
say that there is some vector or
something oh there's so much to say
about these about these things I'll have
to boil it down into into an uh a
shorter presentation well the the uh uh
next but I promise next week uh that we
will get off of that even though I'm
probably not half done yet see you
then